※はじめしゃちょーさん非公式の字幕です
こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです。
やっぱこれから 暑くなるから⇒
やっぱ こういう夏のスタイルがこれからのモテ要素なんですよ。
お前ら 覚えとけ。…
ちょっと買い物に行ってきた訳なんですよ。
ドセェーイ!!　ドッセイッ。
って訳できょうはですにぇ⇒
こちらに 「ハンドメガフォン」をたくさん買ってきました。
ま メガホンの小さい版ですね。
中身は大体… あ～ こんな感じか。
安っぽいな。
こういう… こういうやつです。
メガホンなんですけども。
あ 電池。何個だろう。
単3… 単3？　これ そもそも。
あ 単3電池掛ける⇒
6!?
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8。はちろく48。
48本も要るのよ！
ファッ！
とりあえず 電池を入れます。
うわっ マジか。
あーーー!!
あーー！　ちょい…。
きた。これで 一応 つくはず。
「（メガホン）あ あ。」　おー。
「あー。」
「あ あ。」　あっ 近所迷惑。
「（サイレン）」
「こんな感じか。なるほど。」
「はい。で こういうのが メガホンなんですけども⇒」
「今回ですね こちらのハンドメガフォンを⇒」
「なんと！なんとですね…⇒」
「4980円での⇒」
「お買いもと…。」
しゃべった声を… これを使う事によって 大きくなるんですよ。
それなら みんなわかると思うんだけども⇒
俺の声をこいつが聞いて大きくなる。
で 俺は思った訳よ。
俺がしゃべった声を こいつが聞いて大きくして⇒
このメガホンがしゃべった声を 更にほかのメガホンが聞いて大きくして⇒
更に この大きいメガホンが聞いた音を こっちが お… 聞いて⇒
で これが音を… これを聞く これの音をこれが聞く⇒
で これとかこれを聞くって こう… 円陣を組むと⇒
俺の声が 無限に こう ループして 音の台風が出来るんじゃないかと思った訳なんですよ。
俺… 頭… 悪い… なぁ。
俺 でも 出来ると思ってるから。
とりあえず原理としては⇒
メガホンっつうのは 音を聞いて その音を大きくして出すっていう。
スピーカーのボタンが取れた…。
なので こういう風に円陣を組みます。
こういう感じね。こういう感じ。
（落下音）
ヤバイヤバイヤバイ…！
これ メガホンで円陣を組むんですけども… 円陣を組むんですけども⇒
僕が あー って言うじゃないですか。これにね。
あー って言うと その 俺の あー がここから大きな音で あー って出る。
で その大きくなった あー を… このメガホンの… 俺の あー を拾います 更に。
で このメガホンから出た あー を更にこれが拾って⇒
これの あー をこれが拾う。これのを これが拾う。
拾う 拾う 拾う 拾う 拾う 拾う拾う拾う拾う… ひろろろろろろろろろろろろろろろろろ！
ブァーーーーーーーーーーーー!!
サッソ～ク ヤッテミタイ～ト思イマ～ス～。
よし オッケー オッケー いい感じ。
「（ハウリング）ゥポーーッ！」
えっ！
「（ハウリング）ピーーーンッ！」
なんで？　待って…。
既に音の連鎖が起きているっていう事か。
シーッ。
「（ハウリング）ピーーーーッ！」
待って 待って なんで なんで？
「（ハウリング）フオーン」
おい バカ バカ！
ちょっと 間隔をあけよう。列を乱すな！
間隔をあけろ！　男子 女子 交互に並べ！
「（ハウリング）ピーーッ！」
だから 男子 女子 交互に並べって！
「（ハウリングによる高音が鳴り続ける）」
鳴っちゃダメ 鳴っちゃ… ちょ 待って 待って 待って。
ちょ 待って 待って 待って 待って…。
俺 こ… ダメだ。俺 これ 近所迷惑で追い出されちゃう。
間隔が狭いと なんか 変な 共鳴音みたいなのが… 出すんで⇒
間隔 広めで 行きたいですね。
「（ハウリング）ピーーアォッ！」
お お前！
「（ハウリング）ピー」
なんで！？
「（ハウリング）ピーイィ！」
「（ハウリング）ピーィィ！」
「（小さい ハウリングの音）」
ヤバイ ヤバイ ちょ待って 待って 待って…。
「（大きくなる ハウリングの音）イーーィイーー！」
待って 待って 待って 待って ヤバイ ヤバイ ちょ 待って 待って 待って…。
ハァ… どうしろって言うの これ。
待って な… 変な音 しちゃうんですけど。
苦情 来るよ これは。
フェッフシュ！
俺はこんなので終わるわけにはいかないんだよ。
一回だけ フルパワーで… とりあえず 全部つなげでみましょう。
やるしかねえ。では行きます！全部オン。
「（スイッチを入れる「カチッ」という音から始まったハウリングが メガホンのスイッチを入れるたびに大きくなる）」
「（ハウリングの音が止まない）」
アーーー!!　ウワァーー!!!
（BGM）♪～